[Music]
you might notice
that every time i do that intro it's
only two chords it
may not hurt you that i know more than
two i actually know four
you know four chords yeah i know four
whole chords and maybe next time
i'll do an intro with those other two
chords
i i think i have a mystery reveal
chord reveal board reveal at one million
subs
jake are you playing one new chord we
playing a chord i've never heard before
hold on like 50 000 subs right there
hold on
jake can you have 50 000 subscribers jay
can you pump up your audio
can you pump up your voice really yes
like 2 4 db
[Laughter]
how do i do that the banjo was so loud
your microphone got scared
just bring the mic closer to your face
oh yeah i could do that it's way over
here
oh now you sound wonderful okay sound
you sound awesome now
great so yeah so you guys is this the
first
remote podcast again this is the first
the first one again first full remote
podcast
since since the world ended again since
the world ended again
well there's world war iii with iran
then it was quarantined one
then now it's quarantined world end two
don't forget about the wildfires oh yeah
the fire that's where the fires
the area 51 age oh yeah remember last
year
remember last year the storming of area
51
what a good time there was some innocent
era yeah
yeah man take me back did you
really make a fuss about trying to storm
area 51 and they have nothing better to
do
[Laughter]
that's funny that's really funny yeah
but no one's doing it now speaking of
being quarantined and being at home have
you guys been watching
a lot of shows not really
although i'm trying to find some time to
watch the latest season of norseman
it's that viking comedy show on netflix
and it's
really freaking funny let me write that
down you told me to watch that last time
it's really really funny do you guys
have like uh
i need to watch this list on your phone
i have sometimes i have that yeah okay i
wanna hear what's on it it's usually
it's short
um here let me see if there's anything
on there now
um but since baseball started back up
i've just been watching baseball
why see i got on here
i can check off community i've been
watching that i have parasite i need to
watch that
oh yeah that movie's great get out
jumanji get out's great jumanji
yeah not the old one the new one i heard
is really funny really
yeah cool enemy at the gates gone girl
there will be blood knives out drive
you never seen there will be blood or
enemy at the gates nope
or drive no drive's all right those are
all good
driving is a way better trailer than a
movie
driver is a really good trailer honestly
drive
is a trailer my neighbor totoro
well you know it's also ryan gosling's
first role as like a badass though
so yeah he was good good enough
good enough to be believable i still
actually want to watch blood machines
like there's a lot more is that a
boggling in it
no it's it's that carpenter brute
like sci-fi movie thing
uh it's just it's it makes no sense but
it's really crazy looking
is the for some reason they decide to
have a french actor try to speak with
like an american accent
as opposed to just hiring a guy that
speaks english or
having the guy speak french and subtitle
it yeah it's just it gets really awkward
i mean
it's just the classic thing is like you
have two or three or whatever
like amazing vfx artists and like art
directors
and they're like screw it this is what
we want to make so they write a script
and it's just
you know the script is inversely
like it's it shows about as much
inexperience as the vfx
shows experience and it's one of those
tragic things where it's like
you notice it only get made because they
are passionate about doing it and they
had to you know pour their heart and
soul into it
but you know one of the things that
comes with that is that they have to
write the script and direct it
and you just end up with a thing that's
so beautiful but
so janky you know they should have kept
it in french because the thing is is
that way
then everyone around the world would
like like a lot of
metal you know that i listen to is not
like in
english and i think it's probably better
that way because
like i get the emotion and the tone of
what you're saying but i don't need to
like
hear you you know recite some random
like
viking book you don't have to really do
this
like yeah i don't realize i don't have
to realize how dumb it is yeah
mexican uh ballads are the same way
like for me like i like listening to
them just because they sound nice
and i understand like they're they're
bitching and moaning about something but
i don't necessarily want to know all the
details you know
yeah yeah that's why foreign films
always seem so heavy and like
important just because you can't
understand anything you're saying so
it's like this must be good acting
no you assume it's good acting you know
it's like it gets the acting gets a
a pass he's like you left the fries off
the order
what am i supposed to do
this tragedy is the biggest tragedy that
i'll ever ever have
it's like you know but in another
language just like man the passion
well i feel like that's why anime still
works the best that way too because
you get to read what they're saying and
you hear the emotion behind the delivery
but you know if you were to actually say
the words these anime characters are
saying
you know it's just a meme yeah
exactly just yeah so all our videos are
going to be in foreign languages from
now on because that's the key to good
acting
that's the takeaway that's actually what
we're having the podcast for today
is to announce that all of our pieces
are going to be
in whichever language we feel is most
appropriate
for i mean we're still we're still
shooting them in english but we're just
going to dub them
wait are we i know you're right
yeah you need to then you don't dub them
and then people are like oh what's he
saying
yeah well i hear that's how it like what
is it like uh
like i was reading it like in glorious
bastards and quinn tarantino shot that
um there's a lot of german in it you
know he doesn't really speak german
and so it's like i just like that idea
of like all right you're a german actor
give me the best like german take on
that line and he listens to it he's like
sounded emotional
yeah yeah we'll dub it later we'll put
this up it's like yeah
you looked really intense when you're
saying that so it's probably a good
delivery
that's true i was hooked through those
scenes in that piece
and also a good movie yeah the scene in
the house where the girls are hiding
under the house and
yeah it's a good scene a lot of good
scenes in that movie
yeah yeah that reminds me of another fun
translation fact of how like arnold
schwarzenegger
was not allowed to do the german dubs of
his own movies
because like his voice
and the way he speaks like in german
isn't considered like a
theatrical or like manly sounding voice
or austrian either you know same
language but yeah
like um yeah i don't know if they're
particular about that stuff they might
they sounds like they must be yeah they
hired a different actor
for the german version the history of
germany and austria is
not not always peaceful they've had
their moments of
past i don't know much about it myself
it's funny thank you very
much have you ever seen um
the sound of music oh yeah
classic of course yeah i learned
recently that uh
the actress that played mary poppins is
also the lead in sound of music
and you guys are actress apparently
everybody else in the world did so
yeah crazy yeah
it's a good movie i rewatched it
recently sound of music
wow yeah i mean yeah the pageantry
the magic i mean wow i was actually
researching the uh the way they did blue
screens
it wasn't a blue screen actually for
mary poppins which was another julie
andrews the other julie andrews movie
that we were talking about
and uh you guys want to hear the crazy
tech behind that
sure so they actually had blue screens
like all the way back to like the 50s
and you can pull a key from a blue
screen on film just by using various
like blue and red filters basically like
you know a blue filter lets the blue
light through a red filter basically
blocks all the blue light
so by using a combination of them you
can basically eventually print on the
black and white film a pure black and
white image
by filtering out the blue and then
filtering out the other colors and doing
a couple different passes
and then you can use that black and
white film to project one part of a film
than another part of the film
using that black and white film as like
a mask so
every time they did that they always
have blue fringing which is pretty
similar to what you'd even have these
days with green screen
but then uh a guy working for walt
disney was like
instead of a blue screen which also
means that nobody can wear blue
what if we lit a screen only with sodium
vapor wait so he's knocking at my door
okay
hold on to the story
everyone hold while nico answers his
door
welcome to the corridor podcast where we
really just get down
with you guys oh yeah really
focus and hone in on the discussion
hone in on the discussion and get
something you know get some get the meat
get to the meat of it
well i might as well check my door just
should i
know someone's at my door here i mean
i'm just going to check
just in case okay
no no no no no i felt like it would be
good to just seize that opportunity yeah
no one no don't worry
no one's here okay good yeah no one's
here either
so that's the thing people could show up
any time there could have been someone
about to knock i mean
yeah yeah just the other day just
yesterday i was
i was walking through my living room
sure enough
delivery man right there pulls up yeah
pull right walked right up with a
package
you know could have been any moment a
satisfying moment when you
answer the door before they knock yeah
yep and you're like hey
don't judge us in this place i know
i'm watching my doors that was a that
was a door-to-door salesman
what was he selling pest control
really so you got some ants i'm like i
got ants
he's doing that five after five things
there's a sales technique i learned this
because
control okay we build tiny walls for
tiny creatures
that slowly manage them out of your home
yes in an ethical way that allows them
to survive
outside basically to make a little trail
that goes to your neighbor's house
so we have nested topics here we have we
have to learn about five for five or
whatever it's called and then we have to
go back up and talk about sodium vapor
and mary poppins yeah
yeah so let's just work back up starting
with
out of this conversation hole so five
after five
is when you're in sales and you hit five
businesses or people or whatever
potential clients
after five o'clock wow because that's
when people are done working
and the theory is like that you you go
there
and then they're like ready to have a
conversation because it's prime time in
the middle of their day
yeah little do you know we had a podcast
going on you just bring him in dude
bring him in and bring him in yeah see
if he knows about sodium vapor
all right so sodium vapor right okay
so here's where we're going with all
that so how do you know he's like
hold on how do you light something with
sodium vapor
so such as the chemical
well no like there's old street lights
that you saw
sam sam's introducing the conversation
but
yeah the old orange street lights but
basically it's like the other
noble gases where when you run a current
through it
the gas emits light at a very specific
wavelength so sodium vapor is something
like 540
nanometers or something like that but
it's like it's a very specific slice of
the spectrum
and so they lit a screen with these
lights and then they led to subjects in
the foreground and all that kind of
stuff
and as light entered into camera they
had a prism that would split
just that wavelength of 540 nanometers
or whatever it was i don't remember the
exact number
uh of the sodium vapor light would split
just that one frequency off
into a second strip of film that was
black and white so you'd have your color
film
you'd have your black and white film and
they're both getting exposed at the same
time
but the black and white film is only
seeing the sodium vapor light
so it gives you a perfect black and
white cutout against the background
without having to do multiple filter
processes or anything like that it's
perfectly in sync
and the crazy thing is because it's just
that one
spectrum you could have somebody wearing
blue they could be wearing green they
could be wearing orange even
um there wasn't a color that you
couldn't use because it's just that one
frequency that you can
that would get filtered out um and it
could also do transparency
so one of the things we'll be looking at
in vfx rs react next week
is the scene where they're dancing and
that kind of stuff with like the
penguins
and mary poppins has a veil on if you
think about doing like a transparent
veil
is hard today with a green screen and
they're doing it back in like the 50s or
whatever
with mary poppins damn that's what that
didn't take off
so you can get film this is going to
show my ignorance of the film
world the traditional actual film world
but
you can get film that only records or
captures a certain wavelength
in particular no you i mean you kind of
can but what they had
the prism would split only that
wavelength out to a second strip of film
so that's that strip of film was only
getting hit with photons
that were in that spectrum because it's
the prism that isolated it
so they're rolling two reels at once the
rolling the main footage
for the color image and then a separate
real simultaneously
rolling it's like imagine how like 3d
cameras are
constructed right now where you
basically have
a one-way mirror so that way you have
like one one lens point and you have
like one camera
pointing at your subject and your second
eye is actually usually mounted above
but then they the second camera reflects
to the same because cameras are too wide
to put right next to each other so they
stack them like this usually for 3d
shoots
yeah it's pretty crazy yeah so
being able to isolate that exact like
wavelength let them have things like
motion blur and stuff
and transparent things and they actually
did use it they used it a whole bunch
um these for the birds for all like the
bird elements that be flying across the
screen that's how they got like the
transparent maps for that
and the one catch was that they were
only ever to be
able to build one prism that was able to
split the light correctly
so that they only had one camera in the
entire world that could do
the world's best blue screen basically
what what yeah it's pretty crazy
yeah that is insane yeah cutting edge
that's like
diving in and you know just just
no we'll just make a machine that does
that
yeah i gotta admire that i gotta admire
that that way of thinking though
like yeah he's all mechanical and like
just mechanical i guess you know it's
like all steam
yeah it's all steam it's all steampunk
steampunk film steampunk vfx
yeah the old cameras used to run on gas
and and steam and cold
water vapor i mean everything still runs
in diesel
generators outside of the studio yeah
what kind of power do they got going in
la now
uh you know electricity
i don't know what you're asking with
that question it's like yeah
everything's still steam powered here no
but like
whale blubber from they got the allen s
king plant
right and that's a that's a coal burning
power plant right there's a nuclear
power plant down south of here
that's right there's the san onofre
nuclear yeah and then the rest of it is
just you know
basic old-fashioned coal yeah yeah well
there's some wind there's some
solar there's somewhere crazy laser
discs that
beam all sunlight into one molten salt
well yeah we have those
going on in in the desert right now
yeah man who knew there's google reviews
for power plants
like does google reviews are powerful
really they have wow can can you find a
battery
tonight uh or here we go san onofre
power plant reviews
five stars stayed the night i feel okay
now but i've noticed my hair has started
to fall out
and i've thrown up a couple times five
stars um
one star stop building these on
waterways unacceptable
wow oh wow you said that near what i was
talking about it has 342 reviews
quite a sight from 915 they should post
signs with the name and encourage
visitors
unfortunately i have not been there but
i was able to get amazing aerial view
from plane yeah
if you so apparently birds die in that
ray
if they fly through there they just
immediately are vaporized
like what is this ray the ray of sun in
like the the pyramid sun
in in the desert right before you get to
prim nevada when you're on i-15
oh oh oh that solar plant the ivan paw
solar electrical generator
that's the world's hottest point world's
hottest point
gabe perry here two months ago five
thumbs ups one star review
uses more fossil fuel than to keep the
plant running than clean energy it
produces
literally no way
[Laughter]
like where's the evidence yeah i don't
know it's a nuclear power plant
it's not this one here no this one's
solar oh oh
oh yeah no not the oh here we go not the
san onofre boobs
the the the four stars
four stars for this the nuclear power
plant this
is one of my favorite nuclear power
plants
however the steam generators in the
reactor were cracked and leaking so they
had to shut the plant down
and start decommissioning it it's a
disappointment for an otherwise
exceptionally designed power plant it's
for san onofre
the reactors cracked that's a great
review that's another thing is
dead oh wow here we go one
five four stars four out of five it was
great to live here while i was homeless
they had a great supply of running water
that had some extra flavor
it was definitely not worth the stage
three cancer
but at least i got it at least i got an
extra arm out of it
comes in handy often overall great
experience
although i don't remember much of it
because the cancer ruined me memory
oh my god
[Laughter]
that one is a that's a good review did
you say
did you say that one of the reactors
cracked that one guy said that i mean
maybe it isn't online anymore well maybe
maybe they were repairing it
i guess that would be common it's closed
it's closed yeah it's not actually
you want to shut it down before before
and once again that review is correct it
was closed in 2013 after
steam generators failed okay so you know
corner digital has google reviews
yeah but you can't trust them
hey we got a flawless 5.0 by the way
89 reviews all five stars i'm sure
somebody's gonna
jank it up now that i mentioned it but
yeah but you know it's that's good
it's good while it lasted 89 reviews all
five stars
yeah dude we're like oh my god if
somebody calls the better business
bureau we're number one
yeah we're number one guys welcome to
the corridor casper we're number one
we're number one views in general
proudly number one
uh here's a here's a good one uh two
years ago
from relics he says car less than one
wheel
[Laughter]
uh 10 10 out of 10 would subscribe again
they have an in-house tom cruise double
his name is
clint wrong their special chai tea is
great and so is the udon noodle soup
would eat here and sleep on roof again
well what can i say their t-h-e-i-r
corridor digital
yeah good times good times
so power sound vapor
right yeah well that's pretty much the
end of that one
yeah not much to come back to on that
topic
do you think that's a good youtube
rabbit hole that i uh failed down
recently
great let's do it all right cool so i
found out there's an entire like
subculture and youtube uh
dedicated to documenting fires and
uh watching how the firefighters put
them out and then
just like a whole sweeping community of
people that are just all
armchair firefighters critiquing it
always super critical it's never like
thanks for putting out this home it's
like
watching where these guys put the truck
they just really didn't plan for this
kind of a drafting situation what they
really should have done is poke some
holes in the vents underneath the roof
on the right it's like
it's got to be like all like 50 year old
men just like
debating the best way they should put
out the fire of this house
50 year old volunteer firefighters yeah
and just you know hundreds of these
videos
i really think that's that's the start
of something kind of amazing here you
know like there's
there's ride share services and you know
we're even seeing citizen being like
these
social media style like like you know
crime awareness if they did like a uh
like some sort of peer to peer gig
style firefighting service where if a
fire happens
you tag it with your phone yeah and it
basically goes out to a network of
amateur firefighters yo guys
who all didn't make comments on how
you're doing tell you what to do
differently
yeah but they can also like you know tag
themselves as one of the firefighters
now on that job and they can come in
and actually make a difference what if
we did if we did this for not just
fires but for all public services and
like general services oh my god
like they should deal with cops and
firefighters and ambulances
this guy's uh robbing a a liquor store
uh or it's like help i've broken my like
who
[Laughter]
yeah it's like but you'd make a really
easy quick list of like the problems
you know so that way you know if you are
in trouble you know it's only like one
one click there's only like four or five
yeah ailments listed that are kind of
generalized
yeah you just you have five general
problems that can only happen
and real simple icons you know real
simple icons like
a heart with a crack down the middle or
like an arm
with like a boo boo on it the ambulance
symbol
yeah yeah yeah or there's just like a
question mark
which is like i don't know what's wrong
with me
but i really could use an extra hand
i don't know what i need but i know that
i need help
yeah yeah it's urgent you just get rid
of each
that's like the that's like the random
encounters on craigslist or whatever
it's called on craigslist
yeah and then there's like an actual
button at the bottom where it's like an
extra like five or ten bucks
but you hit that and like instead of a
dude in his like
toyota camry pulling up it'll be an
actual
ambulance like a real a real one like
that's but it's a little pricier because
you know yeah premium yeah it's premium
it's for premium users
extra from premium uber yeah it's like
yeah it's uber red
[Laughter]
the service is called uh
i think the firefighting one though is a
little better to start out with though
because it's called hope it's
h-b-l-y-p-e
hlt h-y-l-t
h-y-l-p yeah
[Laughter]
here for marcus marcus okay marcus i'm
looking for marcus are you
[Laughter]
the why the hylp is like because it sets
it apart
you know or or or this is not funny
because it's just so lame but helper
hlpr
i know they already used fire for fire
but the fire version of that is
definitely
fyre yeah
fire fire helper is the
is the direct messaging system that you
can use
to message other people i guess what is
that
the law enforcement one's police but
with a y2 like p-o-o-l-y-c
police
man yeah i think that works um i think
we should get right on that
we should get up after you launch this
website
yeah it'll be a subscription service
just let me release the subscription
service we're gonna get into that
silicon valley startup game yeah
yeah we're gonna be we're gonna be
venture capitalists in the silicon
valley startup game that's where this is
all going
we definitely need to beta test it in
the most lawless country as a proof of
concept
that's how you do it yeah yeah yeah you
take it to
gosh knows where yeah i mean where's the
place there's got to be some place with
no laws
you know antarctica
yeah places where if you have enough
money it's like there's no laws
yeah i think antarctica is good for like
the medical one but the fire one
i don't know uh ocean you could do it
like the opposite though
things get too cold maybe go to like
micronesia that way if you burn down an
entire
indonesia yeah and it can only go so far
yeah lots of good plans coming out of
this podcast guys
yeah recording this one right oh yeah
christian we're recording this round
let's let's save this one
let's see let's we should save this one
i'm saving it i'll make sure we're
saving it
thanks cool uh well we're going to talk
about the site and
uh i wanted to take some time at least
we should take some time
and spend just a few minutes going
through
like because we did the announcement
video
last week on corridor crew yeah the
future of our company
yeah we got a lot of questions about
what we're doing
and obviously we're going to address a
lot of those in the launch video but
also the launch video is kind of a
separate thing that
talks about like what the site has to
add and so maybe
we take some time and we talk about like
there's a few big questions like
one that i saw all the time guys does
this mean you're stopping youtube
you're creating you're creating a
subscription website so it's actually
gonna be tick-tock only from now on out
guys
yeah it's tick-tock only no so just for
those of you who haven't heard i'm sure
most of you have
but we're doing our own subscription
site
uh quarterdigital.com in addition to
everything we're doing on youtube now
why why
why would we do that why why the heck
are you doing that
well first things first the first reason
is that
youtube in and of itself has its own
ecosystem it's got its own economics to
it and everything you do on that
platform
is wonderful it is as it is everything
you do on that platform
is specifically for that
platform everything you write everything
the way that you write everything you
know by and large
you know there's some exceptions here
and there but by and large everything we
create
for is that on these channels is made
for
youtube the youtube audience and the
youtube ecosystem now
over 10 years we've continued to hone
that
and are fortunate enough to be some of
the people that have success
making a living doing that right
but where do you go from there
say you want to say you want to turn
around and you want to make a
something something something just
hey this is going to appeal to a wide
enough youtube audience to get a large
enough number of views
so that the tenth of a penny that we get
per video
or per viewer is going to be enough to
support the cost that it costs to make
that that only gives you that only gives
you this it only gives you a box
this box and it's like if it doesn't fit
in this box
what else is there for you in life right
there's
there's there's netflix there's other
subscription services
right there's that you can sell your
work to
you can go down the silicon valley route
where you're like
hoping for somebody to come in and
finance a movie but by and large that
that format
of independent movie financing is like
you know
there's maybe like five people 10
people that are doing that right now in
the world
yeah so though
what will people doing their own
self-financing
yeah yeah i'm talking about the
traditional like someone steps
in as a as a financier to find an
independent feature film and then that
goes out through the traditional
theatrical route
oh yeah yeah so and all those companies
basically die after like two movies
right so there's some of them that turn
you know some of them turn into the
bloom houses of the world
but that's why there's bloom house
and like you know a couple others maybe
a handful and then and then you have the
big boys you have the big studio models
that that have their own
system of economics disney you know
marvel studios what have you yeah and
these days that's all kind of based on
tried and true
we know that this sold so we'll keep
making more of it yeah
and again there's nothing wrong with any
of these models like i i don't mean to
like go on a tirade here and be like oh
you could
like no these are all great the fact
that anything
that is uh that occurs in an audio
visual format can be
sold or marketed against to to make
earnings off of so that people can
continue to do it again
is a testament to like the success of
modern times right like and no point
before
this i mean you had people in theater
and stuff like that back in the day but
like
at no point before this have as many
people been able to be successful
at making a living at creating audio
visual content than
now um but it still leaves something to
be desired and that's really what this
whole thing gets down to
it gets down to creating another model
one that doesn't you know again like
remember when we were first starting
youtube and it was all like so is this
tv
is this movies is it's and the whole
thing was like no
it's it's it's just youtube that's what
it is
this is the same thing this is just
our site these are these shows that we
want to make for it
yeah well i think it's been a really big
challenge because it's it's kind of like
a it's over the last decade even with
like movies there's
everyone talks about like the gap of
like oh where's the like
20 to 40 million dollar big budget
action movie
you know you feel it feels like there's
that split where it's like you see that
you know the micro budget thing
exploding and then also the
you know 200 300 300 million plus model
exploding
because you know they can bank on ips
versus the smaller ones now are like all
right well we can bank on
making enough movies so that way when
one is successful they'll
pay off the rest right you know and so
there's
that creates a gap even in that industry
but then when it comes to like the
online
world so to speak like they're like
that that gap there's not even like
another side to that gap right now we
just know what the bottom end is
basically you know it's like it's like
you can do this ad supported stuff on
youtube which
works only if like you are
a one to two to maybe maybe three
creator team
um and but we there's
like that the upper end of that gap
still hasn't been figured out either
um because i mean frankly like anything
that looks produced so to speak on
youtube
is basically made at a loss
um just because yeah that that ad system
can't support it
but yeah yeah you're per minute cheap
like cost needs to be really low for
ad supported yeah i mean that's how we
we've been doing it too
or you have like you know 10 million
people watch your content but
the problem is it's very hard to make
something that 10 million people are
passionate about
well and here's i think the thing that
is puts us in a slightly different
situation than most people why most
people aren't going on making sites
um i mean there are like i've seen a lot
of people
yeah a lot of podcasts and shows
like they'll they have their main site
where they release like the full like
one or two hour video and then they'll
post like a highlight clip
on youtube i've been watching this one
channel called all gas snow breaks
lately and they're just like these
hilarious interviews where they go to
conventions and just
find the weirdest people yeah in the
weeds
but like you know they they have that
model of like all right we're posting
highlights so to speak on youtube but
obviously all the full content is still
on their site
um but yeah it's like
my point was though like it's a tough
situation or it's a tough transition
because i think the main thing is like
the moment you open a subscription site
um there is kind of like or the moment
you start paying for it it's
it's there's there needs to be that
guarantee of some level of quality or
familiarity
you know it's like if netflix was green
lighting
like literally every youtubers movie
pitch
like it would be all over the place with
quality and like
you know so that's subscription already
it's quite all over the place
it kind of is too you know there's tons
of terrible junk on there too but
you know i think the biggest thing is
like you have to be able to guarantee
that like
that level of quality so to speak and
quality comes in millions of forms
not just talking about using a good
camera but like
you know if you're gonna put money down
for something you wanna it's not it's
not
it shouldn't be a gamble so to speak you
know thankfully
after making these videos for a decade
here on youtube i think
we're we've earned a spot there of like
all right
like you've you're probably pretty
familiar
with what we've been doing so um i think
that definitely
has put us in a good position and that's
i feel like the biggest draw anyways for
someone to subscribe
yeah that you're right that that that
that subscription
fee goes into exactly that it goes into
guaranteeing that the stuff that we make
for the site lives and runs on that
model
and that model allows us to
quality control it all the way through
so you know it's it's better
to not come out with 100 shows
or to try to fold in all of our youtube
channels into this model to then all of
a sudden make them work on that model
but to think but to really like the the
thing that i love about the site is that
it boils down
the essence of of what our job is
for the purpose of the viewer it
completely takes
you take out youtube for a second like
obviously if you subscribe to the site
you get all of our youtube content right
ad free and all that stuff but
you take away merch you take away like
other projects that we've done be to go
behind other paywalls
and you just talk about like okay if we
were to go out and make
shows directly for the people who are
paying for them
that's it yeah yeah
yeah well like you know i hate to say it
but like you know
partially just because of like mental
health but also
i think because we're releasing so much
content you know i'm finding myself
recently over the last few months here
like
basically only checking video stats and
not reading comments on
on videos um and that's usually just
because i'm like look
if the video is doing well that means
it's a good video if it's got good
numbers it's a good video
and it's not necessarily what people are
saying and that's because
we've been working in a system for
so many years at this point that like
you that's
that is the metric for success so to
speak yeah
so sam you and i were working on the
script for this launch video that we'll
be shooting over the next couple days
here
and like one of the interesting things
that we're writing about is
this concept of audience and like the
power of being a subscriber so
you know there's this statistic that i
bring up which is right now
and this is true your view on youtube is
worth
one tenth of a penny so when you go and
you watch a video on average
one of our videos on average we're
getting a tenth of a penny for your view
yeah um and so in other words like
youtube really
is it really devalues the viewer the
viewer isn't worth that much
on youtube yeah uh you know whereas in
contrast if you're a subscriber on the
site
like if the number of people it would
take
to equal one subscription for one month
from one person to the site is four
thousand people
so you have four thousand views on
youtube versus one person for one month
on the website so like you know just one
iteration of the subscription
and that's crazy that you know the one
person on our website
is as valuable as 4 000
views or 4 000 people on youtube and i
think it shows you that like
with that metric that shift you know in
power
you can really make something that's
tailored
to the v like to a subscribed viewer um
we can make something we don't need a
huge audience
to make good stuff we don't need a huge
audience to be able to support ourselves
or to go out there and justify making a
really cool piece of
filmmaking because just you have so much
more value and so much more voice and
power
as a subscriber even at a really low
subscription rate
you know versus sitting there and just
trying you know us trying to grind out
the ad revenue little by little from
just attracting as many eyeballs as
possible
yeah it's kind of it's kind of crazy
like i know you've said like this is
what it equals but like i think
what really puts it into perspective is
you let's say you take one of these
channels we're running here let's say
there's a vfx artist react video that
comes out
or i think actually maybe even node's a
better example because
like it's a smaller audience and you
know what we're making is way more
tailored towards
what that audience enjoys and so like
right now with like big in the grand
scheme of things the history of node
let's say we release
a video that gets 400 000 views in like
the first week or so
we would consider that a above big
success a very above average video like
obviously there's a couple that like hit
the algorithm and get a million or two
views or whatever but like
when they hit 400 000 it's that sweet
spot of like hey
this is a really good video and it's not
necessarily hitting the algorithm but
people well they're connecting with them
they like it
and so you think 400 000 people that's a
lot all right so when you start taking
that
division there all right now let's say
you release four of those in a row over
the course of a month
all right so like that is
like 1.6 million views there but the
thing is is that those four videos
when you're comparing that to like the
website or the subscribers on that
we're like wow we got 1.6 million views
oh my gosh so many people like it
yeah that's the equivalent
of 400 people on the website yeah
all right 1.6 million views 400 people
400 people watching four videos 400
people
watching these four videos so it's
nuts it's nuts and so like what that
transforms it to is like
well look we got 400 people like and
they'll
let me remind you imagine these 400
people really care
and like are actually digging this stuff
well it's like
who are you going to listen to you know
are you going to listen to what the
algorithm spits back at you
or this much smaller group of dedicated
individuals
who enjoy this it's not necessarily even
a casual viewing it's like no here's
here's some
subscription money like and you know
ideally that's that's where you find
that perfect balance of like
here's something that can't exist on the
youtube platform
that we like to make and also this
much smaller audience really enjoys to
see and like
it's going to take a little time to get
there but i think that's why the whole
like
projects page so to speak is going to
get us there because we'll
have that direct feedback yeah yeah
that's that's a really i think that
uh analogy really hits at home like
there's been i think people are really
pretty jaded by subscription services
these days especially since
we've gone through now the first phase
of
uh like life forms of subscription
you know yeah we we they all started in
like you know 2010 11 12
and then and then there was there's all
this fervor around them and
all these venture capitalists invented
all and invested all this money
and then you know 2013 14 15 rolled
around
a bunch of the first phases died and
then
you know second phases died i guess and
now we're now we're sort of in like
now we're 10 years basically into like
subscription models in a real way
you know subscription models have been
around obviously a lot longer than that
well actually
you know sorry now that i mentioned it
like when i was talking about the gaps
earlier in content
i feel like the top ends of the gaps for
online content are kind of defined by
your like go 90s and queebies
yeah because what the thing is like
that's that's different from netflix
because netflix
caters towards the like cinema it's like
the low end of the cinema gap so to
speak not to say it's low end content
specifically but from like a like if
we're gonna categorize things broadly
you know netflix has huge movies on it
and stuff so it's like you know it's
kidding for that realm when you look at
the go 90s and qibi's
what they're catering towards is the
high end of the on online audience
yeah so to speak but the problem is is
that it's like so high-end that it's
like
it it almost hits netflix you know it's
like it's like so close
that it's like what this doesn't even
really feel like
are you paying curated yeah like on
who's the audience like who who's making
these videos
that's what i want to know like like
it's because if it's just a
multi-billion dollar corporation then
there's like zero loyalty from the
executives to the creators
so to speak you know it's like if you
really like a show it's like who cares
no one no one there cares
they're just looking at their stats too
investment yeah
you know so so when you think about it
that way like there's been a lot of
people saying oh
you know good luck but i don't think
it's gonna work but good luck
but i don't think people really realize
the disparity and value that
that we're currently dealing with and
and that 400
equals to 1.6 million
analogy it that's that that's the
easiest most direct way to to understand
that
yeah oh and i mean also i think when
when we look at like patreon and stuff
it's like we have our patreon numbers
and like if that's any sense
of like what we can be doing with this
website here
you know i think we're gonna be off to a
pretty good start because you know
patreon alone i mean obviously they're
all converted into subscribers now
yeah anyone who's you know on the tiers
but
like yeah real quick we should clarify
that anybody
this is the one thing will be part of
the launch video but anybody who's a
patreon
or sorry anybody who's a patron or a
supporter at the five dollar tier or
over on patreon gets a free subscription
to the website yeah
and i think that's super important
because i forget who i had the
conversation with
but like i was asking someone like if
they had a patreon i was like maybe at
vidcon
and they responded by saying it's like
now i don't like that because
like you're not doing anything
for them you know what i mean it's like
they felt weird because it's like well
you just
don't is this like a tip jar you know
basically it's like
you're paying for something but you're
not really getting
anything afterwards and they they just
weren't that cool with that relationship
and
you know after after i heard that i
haven't been able to unthink it and so
being able to
basically go hey everyone on patreon
like like
we've we've accessed the api your emails
are now registered you now have a
subscription
it's like something for your support
yeah it's like
it's vindication that's and that's been
the longest and hardest battle with
patreon
is is as it's it's great but it is
there is this element of a tip jar in it
uh
and and it's that obviously for some
people that doesn't
work like you you know some people
are just they want to see us make
whatever we're gonna make and they're
there to support us and they've been
with us on patreon and they've helped
make all this possible but other people
say hey if i'm going to pay something i
want to get something
totally logical right and now with
patreon you can you can do oh we have
live streams which are fun
those are cool you have uh you know you
can you can give out
like different sort of reward tiers but
you can't give
people a vote in what you're gonna make
next and then just i guess you can but
we tried that in the early days but the
system didn't support it you like
the we were like hey high tier high
you know like one of the goals was like
hey we're gonna make like was it like a
last of us mario concept but the problem
with that though was that like
it wasn't just like there's no choice it
was like a one-way road to it and
by the time we got there the idea really
wasn't
really that relevant and so it's just
kind of like oh crap
like we have to mix this up or something
because yeah
it wasn't like true choice so to speak
yeah it's just that i guess i guess you
can make
exclusive stuff and distribute it
directly to your patrons so
they have that but how you know
in terms of like scaling that or
offering it's like
what so what do you do so say say you're
a filmmaker right you go out and you
make a
you go out and you make a show and now
you have a thousand patrons and you want
to distribute that
show to your patrons who paid for it
right what do you
you send them an mp4 yeah yeah
yeah like where's the experience it's a
downloadable file and i know
it's it sucks because like i see some
podcasts i listen to
they got patreons and it's like hey if
you're a patron you get an extra like
double length podcast
but it's like well yeah
i'll download the mp3 i guess there's so
like how do i even
do we used to do that with the project
files back in the day you just have to
upload them
and then you give people a link and then
they can download the project files but
it's like
there's no there's not a real experience
there
you know like not to mention that's just
like to when we were doing it it was
like
hey what do we do with these hundred
gigabytes like we got like kicked off of
like two or three services
for violating terms of service because
of that
like we lost the one in one because if
we would have to pay for it all the
money that came from the patrons would
have
gone into that yeah it was like yeah
like one that's how we lost the
one-on-one account because they were
like
hey uh i know we said like unlimited
bandwidth
but when we said that we didn't mean
like hundred gigabytes
to like you know a few you know people
like see that was like three terabytes
of data right
yesterday and it was just like yeah so
that got shut down
we said unlimited we didn't really mean
i don't want to come off as if i'm
bashing patreon okay like
there's plenty of people on there oh
we're not bashing incredible models
and like have direct relationships with
their audience and
the whole thing created a step
a step to separate artists and creators
being dependent on
like corporate platforms like google and
youtube and facebook
that ultimately require this other
person in the room
mr brand money guy who's spending money
in that ecosystem to make it all
possible
they created an ecosystem that doesn't
have that yeah
and that's great but just what we have
with the site now is a way for us to
make that direct
directly to the viewer and giving them
at least the best product we can offer
you know
videos that's the best thing we can do
so let's give somebody the best viewing
experience for our videos
and a way to help us you know make
even better unique projects specifically
for them
which it gets tough to do that on
patreon for us at least you know yeah
well
yeah because yeah you get caught up with
the whole like all right well
i can't actually do what i do on patreon
but i can make trinkets
you know it's like i can i can spend a
lot of time doing all these like
auxiliary things that
i think can be really cool but then it
ends up being this whole like
weird like little sub system that kind
of prevents
you from doing what the people on
patreon
signed up for in the first place and
they wanted to see in the first place
you know yeah
yeah so um like the current one and
that's why the website
basically does it all boom it's like we
lit
when we pitch the website like what the
list is like
basically all the stuff on patreon
except
now you actually get to watch the videos
without ads
it's like oh that's cool your actual
product without ads
cool and then the exclusive shows blah
blah
but then the merch discount that's not
on patreon
you know i mean the live streams are uh
the livestreams are now hosted on our
site so it's kind of you know hosted
yeah
it's pretty easy we just found like you
know our patrons
have been amazing and have really helped
us
you know make corridor what it is today
because you know up until we had the you
know vfx react and summon react
shows like all of our channels are
pretty much small volume channels
including corridor
because you know corridor we had videos
that come on they'd be big once in a
while but
outside of that you know they come out
once every two months once every month
and you know for us to survive we had to
have you know support from be like
patreon plus
our ad revenue plus our brand
integrations plus our merge sales you
know
combining all these things together and
you take any one of those things out and
suddenly
you know the table doesn't balance
anymore and falls over
but this like ideally the site just lets
us like
going directly to you with the listener
or you the audience member you the
viewer
going directly to that person at the end
of the day
that's what that's where the real
business model lies
and everything up to this point like you
know the 70s 80s 90s etc all taught us
that there needs to be a system in place
between us
and the viewer because at the time there
wasn't you had to have some sort of
technological
solution to deliver the product to the
person right
and then of course napster comes along
and it's like wait a minute some guy in
his
dorm room made a way for me to access
all the music
yeah in the world and he did it for free
and it's free
like and you tell me the multi-billion
dollar industry the music industry
couldn't do this first
they could and it's like oh yeah that's
the situation we're in
you know it's almost a blessing in
disguise that that that already happened
it is definitely because what what
happened there and we started we were
having this conversation just before we
started but like
you had traditional music and take take
music take movies take whatever but like
in this example it's the music industry
they had a hundred years of uh
blood sweat and tears that gone that had
gone into creating this one specific
model
and that specific model was very very
good
at selling cds
yeah at 15 to 20 dollars a cd and
and that was back in the late 90s right
i remember when i saw like a 22
sticker on a cd i was like what the [ __ ]
22
yeah 22 you couldn't buy singles
remember you couldn't buy singles and
unless it was like months after they'd
already been released and played on the
radio
uh you could only buy the albums
yeah there's a whole there's a whole
thing where they play the single on the
radio they put the single on
the album with filler to make you buy
the whole album it was a waste of money
etc
it was a whole machine and of course if
you wanted to listen to it you had to
take the physical device put it in your
physical thing and listen to it
i know oh my god that media somewhere
physically in your place
dude 90s music was just click bait
no limit record yeah you you hire a
really good producer to make one dope
track and then you just like pump out
the rest of the album
and you lead with that great single
do you guys remember no limit no limit
records
no oh yeah
behind the whole operation and they
would come out with new
artists almost every three weeks and
they wouldn't even take the time they
were they were producing
these so massive mass produced
so quickly that they wouldn't even take
the time to do album
photo shoots for each album they would
take a photo they would take a green
screen photo of the artist
and then they would comp it in to a
background of like
jewels and cars and like
each one looked the same yep and it was
just photoshopped and then
the all the albums were exactly the same
and then they took they did they used
the exact same technique every time it
was a new artist with a new song and
then that's
so funny that's the original like
russian diy youtube video mill
successful yeah they would just if
anyone's successful then okay here
here's your second album okay now we're
going to feature you on on master p's
album
okay and now we're gonna give you your
own label and then they
and that's like they did that for like
six years and they just
ran home with it because that was at the
that was at the very
end of when before it all came crashing
down and this is what i'm saying it was
a blessing in disguise is because
they got very good at creating that
model
so that when somebody and of course they
didn't want to give up that model
because if you don't
if you control that model it's way too
profitable to do anything about
even though you're you know effectively
creating a void where
eventually people are going to be pissed
and so as soon as people figured out
that it was all just mp3 files
that were being created around for no
for no money at
all then people were like well what the
heck the music industry is uh
been ripping us off this whole time and
so people were so upset about that
that they just came in and people were
completely okay with like
legitimately complete privacy complete
piracy complete anarchic
privacy sorry piracy
but yeah man if i can get a movie in two
minutes for less hassle than it takes
for me to use a professional service
like
right like honestly like i don't pay
money
because like i pay the money for the
convenience you know i want to
get the movie and watch it instantly
like that's all i want i don't care
about anything else
i'll pay you five bucks per movie for
that to happen
you know that's the thing that's a big
like a critique that i hear a lot of
these days is like
uh it's just turning into like the
equivalent of cable tv from the 90s
where
you pay 70 bucks because you have to pay
five dollars for this five dollars for
this and five dollars for this et cetera
and rather than having one umbrella you
know one netflix with all the shows and
i have to subscribe to like 10 different
things
and it's like that's that's how it's
going to be
honestly but you don't have to exactly
that's the thing in cable television you
had to
tell them yeah but now you can pick now
you can pick which channels you want and
like at the end of the day like
i get the complaint it would be nice if
everything was just under one
subscription
but that's not like there and there was
kind of a brief moment where that's how
the industry was
you know you had like netflix and you
had hulu and that was kind of it
and guess what guys that was the end of
it we'll never ever return to that
you'll there will never ever be just one
subscription again um they just jack up
the price until they got to the 20
cd model without telling you
that's true but you know that's just
that's just how things go you know it's
like we happen to have gone through a
little technological shift
um and you know it was it was great
while it lasted like
hey there was a time when there wasn't
like you know a whole bunch of ads on
the internet it didn't last very long
but there's a brief moment you know it
was beautiful while it was and
it's gone forever and by the end of the
day it's like it's not really a bad
thing like it feels like it's a bad
thing but it's not really a bad thing
to have all these artists able to
independently offer you
their content and for you to be able to
pick from anyone you want
and in turn have that much more powerful
power and importance to that artist
because you're directly just
supporting them like that's the big
thing is the internet's still making
that dream come true of like
hey all you need to do like take your
time build a website put it together and
you can have a direct relationship
relationship
with somebody you can have an actual
industry you can have actual economics
with just you and the person who wants
to consume whatever you're making
you don't need to go through any
gatekeepers you don't need to go through
any other industries you don't need to
go through any other entities
which is how it was back in the day you
had to go through all that
because the the cost of distributing
is really the only cost is the website
and of course you know the data for the
website but that's it it's very it's
insignificant distributing on the
internet
is insignificant generally speaking in
terms of data costs yeah sure it might
cost a couple bucks for a big file etc
but like
yeah you know compared to like having to
haul like
a crate of cds in a truck to a spot
yeah right man
no it's totally and in that from that
perspective it's it's basically free
from that perspective even though it's
not you know there's significant costs
regarding like the bandwidth and the
accessing of the of that
of specifically video files are super
expensive but
um you know it really just comes down to
like how much of your life
you want to waste watching ads right
i think that's a big part of it you know
like like if
i mean how much youtube do you watch
it's like or how many
ad based services do you subscribe to
it's like
over the course of a week or two it's
like the time that adds up
even on instagram it's just like jesus
yeah
yeah now i go i don't know i will i'll
never subscribe to a service
if it gives me ads at the same time i
know
i would rather pay the money and get the
content like untarnished
to offer two tiers of subscriptions
you're telling me that
like whatever their low one is like five
bucks a month but it still has
ads okay so you guys wanna hear
something that's what are you waiting
for
this one's really going to get you're
going to burn your biscuits
okay here we go i'm going to calm down
so that way i can like
shoot right back up all right it's an
example
of what i never want to do with the
website okay
okay so major league baseball
right no yes we should totally do
baseball no
we're gonna do baseball
so i signed up for um for mlb.tv
okay which is this which is the service
that gives you every
regular season game you want to watch
the boys do the big hits in the next
game
yeah exactly yeah now but but here hear
this okay
say you're in la or in or in houston
which has the same basic setup but i'll
just use la because it's the most apt
example
so you buy mltv mlb tv and you're in los
angeles guess what you can't watch the
dodgers that's a bunch of [ __ ] why
can't i watch the dodgers
okay well here's here's why okay so then
say say you're like
okay well it's blacked out on mlb tv
but if i get um you know uh
say i get a re-slung cable subscription
like sling or youtube tv then
it'll surely be on local television
there right
no no it won't really yeah so
you can you can buy mlb tv and you can
buy
uh a a reese a re
slung cable subscription and you won't
get
your home team because they signed a
deal
that with with spectrum just like the
astros signed to deal with a t
to be the exclusive distributor of all
of their home games
so now you can only watch you can you
could have lived in la your whole life
been watching every single dodgers game
you can only watch the dodgers if you
buy a spectrum cable subscription
and because within the package of a
spectrum cable subscription
is sportsnet la which is the only
channel that distributes dodgers home
games
now that is the epitome of what i'm
talking about when when you're talking
about like
well can't you just give me like one
thing and how can everything be under
one roof
it's like but do you want it that way
because
i don't want to pay i'd be willing to
pay if i was a dodgers fan i'd be
willing to pay
40 bucks a month or whatever or 50 bucks
a month even to like get all the dodgers
home games
but you have to buy spectrum cable
subscription to get it
so you have to pay whatever it is on top
of that and then you know of course
they'll be like oh well it's only 29.99
what do you even do with the cable box
exactly and they're going to resell you
then you're going then you then they're
gonna be like oh plus you need our
internet
plus here you need to get this bundle
package where we install a phone line
into your house
that you're not gonna use to keep
watching it's just like
it's just so it's just so convoluted i
just want to get rid of all that and be
like look if you want to watch quarter
digital videos plus
extra stuff that we've never been able
to make before that we're going to
now be able to make and you want to get
all of it directly
just this and that's it and keep it
simple like why can't it just be simple
why can't it just be simple jake you
know what it can be simple and it will
be
simple on corridor digital.com thank you
the mlb has really burned my biscuits
man because the only people who haven't
signed these deals
are bad teams
that have been consistently under 500
that are the only people that haven't
signed these deals
hey just to take things sorry to take
things off of baseball for a second jake
okay i know
i know but uh and turn things positive
for a second i do want to give a shout
out
to all the people that have signed up to
be beta people
users on the site um and help us kind of
like
get through the initial stages of
launching this thing you know we've
started the whole green light feature
with producer points and all that stuff
where people can put their
subscription money towards the show of
their choice
uh and yeah those that people that have
been listening to the podcast here and
have known about the site for a long
time
those of you who have signed up thank
you for helping us kick the thing off
it's awesome i'm glad to see it working
i love seeing everybody in the
hangouts when we do those it's just
really cool to see these things starting
to become a reality
and it's kind of a big leap you know
it's like you can tell yourself like
well
if only i had a you know a really good
producing deal i'd make a movie if only
i had
this big old budget i'd make a movie and
at a certain point just like
i just got to make the thing and so this
is us just going out and doing it
ourselves
you know and directly to you with your
support
we can make what you guys want to see so
i'm i'm super psyched about all that
yeah you haven't been to the site yet go
go check it out quarterdigital.com leave
it leave a comment tell us what you
think
it's still in beta we're still messing
with it but it's uh
it's a good first impression it's almost
done it's missing some of the cool
key stuff with with like all the
exclusives yeah next week
next week we're going to drop all those
a lot of them a lot of them are ready to
push but
i'm not going to wait i'm not going to
do that until they're all ready yeah all
the exclusive new shows are still secret
so yeah yeah we'll see that soon
wow good stuff yes great stuff
all right well guys that was fun
yeah it was i'm gonna make some
hamburgers
what do you want you want pizza
you want to play with a flashlight or
you want to eat pizza
[Laughter]
that pizza company man i'm gonna have to
try them out oh
so good it's quarantined pizza
people doing it from home right you know
i this the whole covet thing has
exposed who the best chefs are
in our city um i've seen a couple other
like little people
popping up tents doing like just walk up
stands in their front yards
in my neighborhood and it's like they're
they are
some of the best chefs i've ever had in
la because there are people so dedicated
to the craft that they're willing to
have a storefront in their front yard
and
yeah it's pretty pretty amazing that is
awesome
yeah they get to do it without
inspections it's kind of a gamble
it turns but that's the thing it turns
out that's 90 of the time
yeah that's how everything starts
without inspections
uh yes good stuff all right gentlemen
it was really nice ending the work day
with a cool conversation with with all
y'all
oh hold up hold up last thing uh if
you're listening to the audio only
version of this podcast i'm sorry this
last part
requires a visual but youtube.com
quartercast all right one second
what is he gonna do where is he going oh
i know what he's doing he's got a photo
oh
just don't don't even say what it is
we're not even going to say what is just
show it on screen
and be completely silent i know what
this is
this is a quarter cast exclusive here we
go
wow what a reveal our founders
what a reveal look how cool we are i
have a dragon button up shirt on
i know
yeah i'm trying to figure out what sam's
wearing i'm wearing a van halen shirt oh
you are
indeed you are oh wait hold on let me
take it out of the
wax
ruining it oh there you go wow look at
that glass founders
high gloss i like how you guys both have
the same like
jeans and and dark shirts on too
like that yeah some nice coordination
going into that photo shoot
yeah it's a great photo yeah thanks
sam's mom
yeah who knew who knew there was a
better photo than the one we already
have hanging in the studio
yeah also taken by your mom
but the thing is is that that photo is
living proof
that two idiots of the camera
can one day make videos
that are still kind of stupid
[Laughter]
yeah man seriously go out and do it if
you want to go out and do it it's going
to take time
but if you like it it shouldn't matter
it's going to take enough time
from you looking like that to looking
like this
[Laughter]
yeah uh all right all right guys that's
been good
yeah good talking to everybody thanks
for listening nice time see you in the
next one
later